the next day we continue to cross the
first set of lakes the Mississippi flows
through with a new sense of urgency
because of a sudden drop in temperature
to 24 degrees and freezing wind
the goal was Minneapolis 400 miles away
and if we don't hurry a Minnesota winter
storm will be upon us and that doesn't
sound so awesome our support crew brings
us a new method of travel an aluminum
center console boat outfitted with a
shallow running jet drive motor with it
we should be able to get a hundred miles
a day versus the twenty per day in
canoes it's like something out of a
James Bond movie
dodging submerged rocks and logs that
could easily end our journey in the
first few miles I quickly realized how
this could be a fairly dangerous method
of travel
we've got the hard stuff out of the way
now we're in our our jet boat now it's a
little bit skeptical I was like you know
we're gonna just beacon doing this the
whole thing guys like I did it years ago
this jet boat is it's pretty sweet
these next 400 miles were meandering
through with much bigger obstacles and
in watch Steven navigators was quite
impressive the jet boat experiencing of
getting into the jet boat the turns for
the boats sliding and I'm having to kind
of feather it through a corner then
bring it back and then feather it around
a rock or through a gap you know I've
always wanted to run one NASCAR race I
feel like this is almost my NASCAR right
you know it's a deal where you can't hit
the wall you're out of the race
it's a experience where you know it's
freezing cold outside and here I am just
I feel like I'm swimming so that it's a
total adrenaline rush
I gotta go
one of the reasons that we chose the jet
drive is there's a lot of water that
we're covering over this next 400 miles
that are interesting the jet drive you
know you can literally run and four or
five inches of water I've been set up on
this boat
it's just you know half an inch lower
than the actual bottom of the boat if
you have a regular engine and had a prop
driven type boat here you have to have
probably 18 inches of water to be just
to be able to run there's so much of
this water you can't take a prot style
motors in basically you would just get a
knock the lower unit off one stump or
one log floating and a guy comes across
it and just shears the lower unit off
not feeling that
I don't know I don't know what we could
a kid unless it sucked a piece of that
wood up in there behind the behind the
propeller that you feel you feel like
doing something you know this river is
loaded with what I would call River
mines it's you know logs big boulders
sandbars that if you don't make the
right decision you're stuck you smack
one of these big logs and you just
totally destroy the intake and you're
down this thing is just littered with
obstacles Steven says it's jacked up
which I assume is a bad thing we've lost
full power and could only manage a few
miles an hour with absolutely no cell
phone service and in the middle of
nowhere
frustration begins to set in seriously
how could it get worse
you